[Music]
a trial pain news submitted by lights
cameras shut the [ __ ] up that's what we
used to say all the time a Saudi
princess is now on trial for allegedly
ordering an unnecessary attack on a
contractor are you laughing because I
kept it yeah of all people is she think
the one that normally people don't oh
really are you like the boxers all right
no make me see that you this whole time
what do you want for me Oh as long as I
have permission he's here he's down he's
having a blast watching that I realize
aren't doing it that's the problem I
thought is like that is a stranger is
the one is there a later like sorry I'm
sorry
this is don't call it do you go ball
okay cuz of my shirt yeah it's a racecar
shirt not a bowling shirt i prettiest
lee i got this for free off of a show is
that what I'm going to do is it a
racecar shirt no that's a bonus for sure
that's I'm picking my son up at the
principal's office right oh no that's
like dad in Florida yeah I do your
sandals on - no but those leather sandal
yeah I have these on now cuz I'm super
hip now oh that makes it better better
shoes my leather there's a Bofors tip
it's called dad where okay loafer the
leather woven ones loafers alright
anyway we're talking here about this
boat do you want to read the headline
again yes there's about take I think I
know sorry we do a whole episode about
city guys a Saudi princess is now in
trial for allegedly ordering an
unnecessary attack on a contractor got
it hey look girl what kind of contract
you're like a house contractor or like a
military contract oh no like a house
country Oh craftsman that's so funny
what do you mean [ __ ] and he gets [ __ ]
over by the security like that guy
Disney lamp yeah yeah oh the sister of
Saudi
powerful Crown Prince Mohammed bin son
al saud safe access
celery's I wondered that so she is now
on trial in Paris because she's facing
allegations that she ordered her
bodyguard to beat and humiliate a
contractor who was renovating her luxury
apartment three years ago
white people films so this this guy the
contractor guy he's Egyptian born but
he's a French national in case you guys
were curious why it's pretty funny
beating up French people though no can
he beat up a French guy they're just
cussing our French it's pretty funny
sounding idea I heard my [ __ ] in a weed
a PU key macaca the way he used did a
really nice French ex-nun el shamah belt
can see just wow that's probably know
anything okay so apparently what
happened here is that he was fixing like
a piece of furniture and then so he or
he was working in in a bathroom and so
he took photographs of the furniture for
reference and that's when he noticed
that the princess reflection and flush
[Music]
so if you notice that her reflection was
in the mirror and that's when she this
is all coming from him but that's when
she saw him and ordered the bodyguard to
take his phone and then he manhandled
him kicked him in the face and then that
the princess insulted him saying quote
you're all the same bastards dogs you'll
see how you should speak to a president
how one should speak to a royal family
yes dance yeah I should play she took a
picture of her accidentally I was
attacking him from that's his story yet
so this is you might have been trying to
sneak a selfie
so yeah exactly this is from him and so
she so ban the bodyguard put a gun to
the back of his head
now your drunk tank gave them two
choices kiss the princess's feet or risk
further assault I would just kiss the
feet immediately wanted you want an
interaction with the princess the King's
feet he probably got stank feet yeah she
got manicure tozi hey that's a lady's
foot I saw video of the Pope just
licking people's feet yes yeah dude he's
got people he's got them all like lined
up and he's like yeah it looks like he's
looking to me but he goes oh he just
lines people they made that like a part
of his duties like you must kiss the
furious people he said yeah yeah but you
were expected to be the opposite like
instead of washing the feet he goes in
and he goes I think it's like as the
Pope you're supposed to be one with the
people and that's the way that you
humble the Pope is he's supposed to kiss
your toesies
kiss your prozis and then I'm going back
to my [ __ ] castle is it like you
watch oh maybe that's right yeah anyway
this princess makes she's a Pope and I
don't like it
breezy so then he was released from the
apartment and so police questioned the
princess for two hours and then let her
go and then three days later she left
the country and they've been now this
judge has been trying to contact the
princess several times but he she won't
answer
she's like new phonus yeah she can't
they can't reach her and then finally
they issued an international arrest
warrant for her [ __ ] yeah big deal
exactly so now they're saying like the
princesses side is saying that they deny
the allegations saying that he rushed to
the princesses side when he heard her
screaming I was sorry that was a
bodyguard and then he said I have never
been violent I did grab him and then I
held him because I didn't know who like
his intention so he said that he assumed
that the the contractor was planning to
distribute these private photos of the
princess taking it because it quote
every Arab wants to take her picture
she's really famous because there have
not been any photos of her published
since she was 8 years old
was a trooper she got twist so the judge
is saying like how would people even
recognize
like oh she's so grown-up mm-hmm
so now what so now there's they saying
that you know oh because then the
contractor also had marks on his wrists
mm and the bodyguard so he had no
explanation for that
and so they asked for a six-month
suspended sentence for the princess and
an eight-month suspended sentence for
the bodyguard in a 5,000 euro fine for
each which is about five thousand six
hundred dollars that's penny changed her
shoes but this is in French Court yes oh
so this is this all went down in France
yes oh and the suspension is they can't
come back for six months oh I don't know
suspended from what protects my thing
from France like school yeah she's like
you can't go shopping here you're
suspended by the you can't go to the
Louvre know what she looks like why is
she hiding her identity yeah trying to
know her Oh or like or like trying to
kidnap her
or maybe it's it feels like a horrible
you know maybe she's supposed to say
Pierre in some way maybe looks like
you're not supposed to be photographing
for some reason I believe her well we
should believe women first are they do
they cover up with the hid jobs and
stuff yeah I'm not okay I forget which
oh so maybe she was out in her her
bathing suit or whatever yes or whatever
and maybe they have a National Enquirer
out there and she was afraid that it'll
be set and that would shame her family
or something yeah like I don't know well
yeah that's what they're so this whole
thing they're saying that they will be
requesting an acquittal and they're
saying that this media coverage of this
case has been unfair to the Saudi royal
because now she's got more attention on
her you need to hold a gun to the back
of the guy's head and do all this
violent beat up stuff that's what were
they happen he didn't do anything I
don't even know what happen if you took
a picture of someone it's like without
the permission that's just a dick move
to anybody like we're getting in trouble
with that watching people do that [ __ ]
on Twitter but just take the guy's phone
and be like you will never come back
yeah that's crazy yeah
but the head a kind of power though [ __ ]
I want to be a pretty thinking about it
and I'm just like if if like I'm
constantly getting harassed I'm like
okay I need to get [ __ ] aggressive or
my bodyguard needs to get aggressive um
so that look at me word travels you know
what I mean like don't [ __ ] with this
[ __ ] because she's extreme this is
exactly what happened in Aladdin did
y'all see it Princess Jasmine no one
knew what she look like
Oh Aladdin and she pretended she was a
the princess's assistant and then she
got to go be around town and be a
regular girl for a little while yeah
well everyone did but this new one Will
Smith it looks pretty good really
popping soundtrack alia Baba say we like
it okay he got dosh got doxxed well dude
you're the secret that pop how did they
keep it so that there's no photos of her
for that long hey here's how ya be their
own up Jesus and I know you guys like
think it's crazy that I want to be a
dictator really bad but these stories
are very you know alluring any boy would
dream of to be a powerful royal with
unstoppable force oh yeah
don't they like background check the
ever living [ __ ] out of contractors that
work in any like Royal sense or like he
could lie there background check yeah
hell and high heaven maybe they found
him after he got cleared maybe they he
had a run-in with the bed people and
they're like hey we're gonna pay you
take care of your family do all this get
us the [ __ ] it's a lot this should be a
lifetime show yeah but you gotta live in
the country where you have absolute
power because like if you're in America
or Europe or whatever you know it's it's
a little too democratic like I mean I
know I know Kim jong-il he kidnapped a
sushi chef from Japan because he loves
sushi so much and he [ __ ] tell them
captain in North Korea thanks trip I
wouldn't go I know who's gonna go be
like I'm down a quarter North middle who
actually was invited yeah then he was
forced to just stay afterwards so he was
eating yeah cuz they get scouted they
actually he has like a team of guys that
go out and in Scout chefs and all that
and then people come in to North
they'll cook for the the Royal or the
the Li family they're the Kim family
yeah and then you liked his sushi so
much he's like why don't you stay if he
was like no I'm good and he was like why
don't you stay yeah there's a
competition in France every year of
baking competition and whoever makes the
best bread the reward and the winner of
the baking competition gets to deliver
the bread to the president every day for
a year but is that kind of also like a
burden every day 6:30 he's like but I'm
[ __ ] in a year I think they feel like
the most prestigious like the greatest
thing that you can have as a baker sure
they have medals for that I think what
if you didn't like that president though
like good silver into trauma some like
dude if kim jeong-hoon asked me to make
him pizza or some [ __ ] I would make him
a shitty pizza so he wouldn't keep me so
that guy that that Japanese sushi chef
he was released I think when Kim jong-il
died right but then Kim jong-un
invited him back he goes back willingly
why they're just friends maybe he was
treated very well because he's like well
what's your wife's name I get marry
right and then you have two kids and
he's like aw [ __ ] yeah yeah I'll stay
yep oh I dream of being a dictator
[Music]
[Music]